fire-based recently released a new query
method called limit to last it's
available in version 7.3 or greater of
the JavaScript SDK and in today's video
I'll show you exactly why it's so useful
by implementing a pagination feature
with firestore if you're new here like
and subscribe and check out a discount
code in the description below for Black
Friday it's active now so feel free to
use that if you want to become any Pro
member you'll get access to the
firestore data modeling course along
with a bunch of other advanced firebase
content for today's video let's start by
talking about the problem that we're
trying to solve you may have a large
collection of data that you want to show
to the user in batches or in other words
you want to split your data into a
discrete set of pages and allow the user
to click through those pages if you've
ever tried to implement pagination and
firestore in the past you might know
that it's pretty easy to go in a forward
direction but going backwards to a
previous page was not so easy
you'd have to follow these four steps
which just isn't very intuitive or
something that you would think would be
relatively easy well I have some good
news for you the limit to last method
makes this process much easier it's
similar to the existing limit method but
instead of limiting to the first end
results it limits to the last end
results over the next few minutes we'll
look at the implementation details from
scratch but I first want to show you the
query functions that make this possible
and make sure to stay tuned until the
end of the video because I'm going to
discuss some of the limitations of
pagination and firestore in general for
this demo we'll be using spelt along
with a new library that I wrote called
spelt fire the pagination queries and
principles applied to all frameworks
across all programming languages but as
you'll see in a few minutes spelt fire
provides some special magic to make
pagination even easier but I know not
everybody's using spelt yet so let's
start by just focusing on the queries
that we need to make for pagination to
work the first thing you'll need to do
is make an initial query on your
collection it needs to be ordered by a
certain field and should be limited to a
specific page size so that's pretty
straightforward but when you want to
navigate to the next page you need to
offset by the last result in that first
page this is pretty straightforward and
uses query methods that have been
available on fire a store from day one
so here we have a function called next
page which takes the last document from
the first query it warders by the same
field but uses the start after method
which will offset from that
ah you so you'll start after the field
value from the last document by the same
field that you're ordering by and it
should limit by the same value as well
now let's say the user hits the next
button a few times but now they want to
navigate back to the previous page in
that case we want to grab the first
document on the most recent query in
this case we'll offset
using the end before method and finally
that's where limit to last comes in that
will give us the results that were seen
on the previous page giving us a full
forward and backward pagination system
now let's take a minute to look at the
full implementation details and spell
the first thing we'll do is install
spelt fire and again this is a library
that I wrote and I'm very excited about
it because it unlocks some UI patterns
and firebase that are really awesome and
if you want to see more videos about
spelt let me know in the comments
because I would be more than happy to
make them the first thing we'll do is
install spelt fire it provides several
components that allow you to access data
from collections documents and user
authentication then we'll initialize our
firebase app in the app component and
use the firebase app component from
spelt fire to set up the context from
there I'll set up a couple of properties
on the component the page size will be
three and the field that we want to
order by is the user name from there
I'll simply paste in the query code that
I showed you earlier the only difference
is that the query is now a function and
the reason we do this is because spelt
is reactive so anytime we change this
function it will update the query that
we send a fire store and update the data
in the UI so now we'll go back into the
UI and we'll set up a collection by
using the collection component from
spelt fire and we'll give it a path of
customers which will read the customers
collection and we'll pass in our query
function as a property to that component
and again whenever the query function
changes it will re execute the request
to fire store now here's where spelt
gets really awesome because it has this
thing called slot prompts it allows me
as a library author to create a variable
in the template called data that is the
data that is unwrapped from this
collection when the data has actually
loaded we can go ahead and loop over it
and show the customer username the ID
and their avatar image under the hood
spell fire is also keeping track of the
loading state very similar to react
suspense if you're familiar with that so
we'll use the loading slot to show a
loading spinner before the
is actually loaded from there we'll go
ahead and set up a couple of buttons
that can run our previous page and next
page functions to go to the previous
page we need to grab the first element
from the current query to go to the next
page we need the last element in the
current query normally we would need to
write some extra JavaScript to calculate
these values but in smelt fire they're
made available as slot props so we
simply say let first let last and as you
might imagine that gives us access to
the first and last documents in the
collection and that's all there is to it
we're now running a paginating query and
fire store they can go in both the
forward direction and a reverse
direction but before we wrap up the
video I do want to talk about some of
the limitations with pagination and
firestore the biggest one in my opinion
is splitting your data into a discrete
number of pages if you want to show a
number of pages and have the user
navigate to a specific page it's really
just not possible on fire store at least
not out of the box if you really need a
feature like this it is possible using a
cloud function to aggregate your data on
the back end when it's created I have a
snippet on fire ship i/o that shows you
how to do this so check that out if you
really need it and also you can use an
offset operator but it's only available
on the admin SDK for nodejs so that
could be very useful as well but again
only works on the server now the next
thing I want to point out is not really
a limitation but more of a caveat that
you should be aware of if your data
changes frequently you might get
unexpected results in your paginate
queries for example if the user is on a
given page and then you add a new
document to the collection it could
change the results on that page so the
data would jump around instantly which
would be a weird behavior then if they
click back to the previous page they'll
get a different set of results than they
saw originally so the bottom line here
is that pagination is most well-suited
for collections that don't change
frequently and that are not real-time
this is especially true if you do
something like infinite scroll which is
just a fancy way to do pagination
because you generally don't want the
position of results to change after they
were loaded in initially I'm gonna go
ahead and wrap things up there if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe and make sure to use the
discount code before it expires on
Friday thanks for watching and I will
talk to you soon
[Music]